thank you
[Music]
so um there's a bill being proposed in
la oh [ __ ]
why'd you have to say la dude
it's some [ __ ] dumbass rule it's
gonna be a dumbass rule I bet it's like
you can't leave uh if you own this
property if somebody wants to lay down
in the hallway they get to live there
you have to pay them or it's like a sick
rule or if like you shoot more than two
people then you're free for sure
in a robbery yeah uh definitely the
people that are going to be affected by
this law do not like it at all because
they're the law-abiding citizens I bet
they're just normal citizens yeah so
here's the law
um it's not it's not like they're voting
on it now they still have to vote on it
to be included in the 2024 ballot so
that it's like still steps away from
being you know is this the homeless one
yeah so they're um they're proposing
that
all hotels in La every day by 1 pm or
something like that have to report to
the city how many rooms are vacant and
they have to give them to homeless
people whoa is hilarious dude that's
crazy wait so it doesn't matter that's
wild it is my dream though like to book
a hotel like at the DoubleTree or
something and then for Taiko to come out
and then know that there's like homeless
people [ __ ] next door or there's a
homeless dookie on the floor that's like
yeah it's a dream life you know missed
you because you get a little you know
knocking he's gonna move back dude you
know what though like now that I live in
Vegas and I live in Honolulu
um look at you yeah I could throw that
away any other tourist destinations but
the point is the point is with my lavish
lifestyle I'm still amongst the homeless
right like because I'm hanging out at
thrift shops even in I'm in these you
know International like I forgot you're
internationally homeless exactly that's
cool man you made it but that's a title
right there the way we talk about
homeless people right is like if I if I
basically any other city I think I'd be
more like oh you know what like they
need some help like because
La homeless is like a special breed yeah
like you have the best when you live
here you [ __ ] get it and you're just
like oh yeah I can't wait to be next to
him and hang out and [ __ ] get bit and
then [ __ ] come down
yeah like but then like but then when
you're like like dude when I was in
[ __ ] like I was just in Waikiki
we're on the beach right and then this
homeless dude just [ __ ] gets Buck
Naked bows to the beach pulls out a
conch and goes and I'm like yeah that's
cool those are my people I know that's
like me right yeah that's literally the
reflection in the seafoam just like this
homework guys I can't believe he's doing
this you have to
yeah I'm next to him
he's like man this homeless guy is weird
it's killing my vibe and this homeless
guy's like I can't believe these people
have ocarinas now yeah I mean I got
blessed by a homeless Shaman this dude
pulled up in his [ __ ] Costco cart
right he busted out some sage and he
started [ __ ] blessing my house and he
did like a dance and then he just walked
away and I'm like well this is different
from L.A oh yeah you know in La this
guy's taking a dump on my [ __ ] like
doorstep I've had all those instances
and you have right so then like I smoke
crack on my steps multiple times it's
about what we can't see but he can see
he sees Spirits going ah they're melting
and going and and transcending the great
beyond he said he's seeing something
more beautiful than what that guy said
but then if you if you're if you're from
these other cities right you feel like
La folks are heartless because they're
like how can you say that about homeless
people because like in homeless people
in other cities aren't like La homeless
people like homeless people in other
cities though they're like hey I'm
hungry can you give me some money and
then like you make up you give them food
or whatever they're like thanks and it's
like a normal exchange out here like you
give them a sandwich they're like I'm
vegan bro I don't eat that [ __ ] you
stupid and that's a different kind of
homeless person yeah and then they set
your house on fire for offering them a
meat sandwich dude or if you give them
fur they pour paint on themselves
man that's not what the point is so a
lot of the hotel because there's a ton
of hotels that are privately owned just
by regular people like they run them
like small businesses and maybe have
like one some of them are Mom and Pop
Shop exactly yeah so that you know their
opinions are just like how could you
expect us to tell our guests who are
paying that they're going to be sharing
spaces with you know people that are
doing stuff that they can't even do
anything about it it seems like just a
Band-Aid of like the government not
trying to have have their own way to
deal with it right wait is the
government going to subsidize it though
are they paying for the rooms yeah
they're gonna have to well they they
have programs right so well not in L.A
that I'm aware of in the same way that
like so in
um uh Washington
they have these uh homeless shelters
that they built right like homes like
affordable housing but there's a program
attached to it they can't seem to get
people to stay in these homes because
the program attached to it is you can
only stay here for one year you have to
pass a drug test and a sobriety test to
stay here and so a lot of the people who
are there are like [ __ ] this I don't
want to do that I'll leave and so that's
kind of part of the problem is that they
can you know they can just decide yeah I
don't want to go by these rules yeah so
even in in Seattle or or yeah Washington
I don't know exactly where it is it's in
Washington but they can't keep these
this affordable housing Place filled so
everyone always says like man what are
we gonna do about this problem well
they're building they're building
solutions to the problem but then they
can't even fill those places and keep
themselves because it's just like what
they did for Echo Park when they cleaned
it up they had to get all these people
out of the park so they offered
everybody hotels and some people are
like I'll just stay here yeah you know
that's what was happening in Venice they
had housing in space for all the people
there and they're like getting them on a
list all this stuff and then some people
were just like nah stay yeah the rules
man you know but even La I hear that the
the
waiting list for the housing affordable
housing is like two to five years so
even if you put your name on the list so
you got to survive as a unhoused person
for like five years to have a chance at
the program no they won't build new
developments exactly and then on top of
that you also have to qualify for X Y
and Z but then again it's like it does
seem like it's lost hope I like how they
do it I think it's oh man I think it's
in Finland right or Norway or something
like that where they give you like a
hundred dollar allowance a day or some
[ __ ] like that you have to give you a
house and they give you a certain like
stipend or whatever and then like they
have access to all these mental health
programs over there that's what we
really need though because if a dude's
out there trying to bite people a work
program is not gonna work nah they
should go into it well aren't there some
people that like just feel too far gone
like if a dude is dumping his bucket of
diarrhea on someone else's eyes early to
come back from that yes there is what is
it I don't know I'm just being a
politician right yes there is this feels
like it's the it's like the hotel
version of Section 8 housing but but
that that's hard though because like
realistically um even with the unhoused
population in La there are so many types
of cases right it's not not everyone's
crazy not everyone's biting people not
there's for like I even saw like an old
like Asian dude you know like a older
guy that doesn't even look unhoused or
anything like that which is genuinely
like we're in a recession probably just
lost everything maybe something really
really terrible happened and that's just
a situation but if everybody kind of
gets clumped into this like here's this
giant problem of homeless people and
they're all wild and crazy and we can't
do certain things I think that also
doesn't exactly like help fix it you
don't think we should lean on
stereotypes nah
I just I just go go I live life based
off of anecdotal evidence because that's
as good as you know my experience is as
good as [ __ ] God's word so like
whenever I see if a man tries to bite me
that's it after that I'm not helping
know how they're all biters they all
bite I just go and buy my personal data
on my own situational they're always
[ __ ] pyrotechnics I'm like okay I
know there's a [ __ ] someone out there
is Will Smith from pursuit of happiness
but the ones I see aren't and I'm
defending my business every day in
downtown as if I'm playing a [ __ ] uh
Plants vs Zombies or some [ __ ] yeah but
you gotta interact with like the certain
homeless people and you know what kind
of homeless they are you know off the
Jump yeah just like by like you could
tell when some of them are the biters
some are like the public defecators you
see someone else but also I I personally
like prefer
helping out or like giving money to the
[ __ ] uh Taco guy in the corner
because he's working and he's probably
homeless too you know what I mean but
it's just not the same it's not like a
crazy rabid guy trying to [ __ ] on my
door like yeah that guy I don't feel
like I can help him I'm not skilled in
that way I like what that congresswoman
was saying when people were talking
about how gas prices have actually she's
like just buy an electric car you
[ __ ] idiot I know right like to me it
like and I really I thought I was like
man okay yeah I need to remember her
name because I'm definitely voting for
her but then I was like I was like to
homeless people I'm like just buy a
[ __ ] house like yeah yeah like what's
the what's the hold up problem is
unhoused then house yourself but I
definitely agree that there's they're
different in certain like areas in
certain circumstances and situations
yeah and often they cleaned up their
homelessness in like six months though
they just kicked them out yeah they just
kick them out that's like ship them to
Washington DC they shipped them all to
Honolulu that's like the equivalent of
like when when 90s kids in movies put
all their [ __ ] in the closet and it's
all stacked up is it clean in here
hundreds of homeless people fly out so I
went through a deep dive of the
homelessness because when I was living
in downtown L.A I was like why is it
like this and it's been like that since
I was a child I just remember you go to
downtown it's homeless Central right
like it's it's been there since I was
born Skid Row's been there it's been
there yeah and I'm like why like we have
so much money in our city how come we
can't [ __ ] fix this problem and we
even um donated to a campaign to uh our
our entertainment lawyer who was he was
actually trying to get in and clean up
the whole corruption and system in the
in the homeless um things uh like what
do you call it in the in the non-profit
and everything that there's a whole
racket behind it and and and he wanted
to clean it all up
he lost obviously but in that process I
did my own [ __ ] um research and and I
came across this one documentary and the
social worker was saying like if you
look at the problem in thirds a third of
them are just they need mental health
like like they need help where they're
not gonna be able to like survive on
their own yeah another third is they
need help like with drug use and [ __ ]
like that and they're so far like into
that like addiction that they can't come
back into the real like world but the
other third
there's about 33 percent ish where they
can come back and those are the
transitional ones that everyone works on
where like you give them some they're
temporary right so they might so they
might be down on their luck maybe they
got their house like repossessed or
whatever
um so they house them real quick but
they're saying like
usually women with children immediately
they get priority but the hardest is
like if you're a young male so if you're
a young male they ex they all expect you
like you could get a [ __ ] job you get
there's no programs for them so then
they're like it's easy for that set of
homeless dudes to get into the drug
because they're so like down and out
that they start abusing drugs and
alcohol and then they they get to the
stage where they're so far gone with the
drug use that they're not like you can't
help them anymore so it's like what they
try to do is the guys that can be saved
um and like maybe they can find the job
and get back on their feet that's what
that that's the population they focus on
so that means like there's 60 something
percent out there that just are really
like in [ __ ] conditions yeah I actually
give homeless people 100 a month
and force them to follow Nancy Pelosi's
trades
they'd be bothering
away okay she's 10x in him yeah she's
over and then they can take that money
do whatever they want yeah this this
hotel this hotel thing feels equivalent
to like you know like if if you
collected everybody's opinions who are
like no you guys should just give these
guys houses anywhere okay they live with
you now yeah it's the same feeling these
Hotel owners get with like whoa what the
hell you're throwing someone else's
money onto this problem so everyone that
votes to do this maybe there there
should be an address for them to being
like you have to house one put them in
an extra room in your house have you
guys seen a homeless guy in Beverly
Hills though and have Beverly Hills oh
they don't keep them over there dude no
it's just while King in Phoenix he's
researching for oh wow yeah
foreign